joining us now senator lindsey graham
south carolina senator thank you for
being back
let me let me go first to this you and i
had um
i don't think you mind i we had a
private conversation about
the the 10-day audit and you went into a
great explanation
you just didn't think it was ever going
to come close to working
and that you were even saying then
we should move on okay i disagree with
you but
you know we have agreed on a lot and
sometimes they're going to disagree
right i don't like what's happening in
restaurants and airports to any of these
people
yeah well number one i want to thank the
police who came to my aid
i know people are frustrated i wanted
president trump to win
so badly i thought he was a
consequential president
i think he made the world safer and more
prosperous
i'm a constitutional conservative i
believe in federalism
even when i don't like the outcome
there's a process under our constitution
i
followed it the best i knew how i stand
my
by my vote but now tonight i'm calling
on
vice president-elect biden to pick up
the phone
and call nancy pelosi in the squad to
end the second impeachment
president trump gave a statement last
night that was helpful
uh it hit the mark he wants to move on
to a peaceful transfer of power
he wants this to end i've been with him
most of the day he's going to focus on
his agenda
his successes for the american people in
the next few days but joe biden said
it's up to congress regarding
impeachment no president-elect biden
is up to you pick up the phone call
nancy pelosi chuck schumer and the squad
and tell them
stand down this will destroy the country
even further
you have the power to do that the
question is do you have the courage to
do it
i told my supporters at home the
president of the united states so i
admire and supported
that it was time to move on it was over
i'm asking no more of you
president-elect biden than asking myself
pick up the phone and tell pelosi
schumer and the squad
to stand down no more impeachments why
would you expect it when
did you ever hear joe biden once talk
about the dirty russian dossier
do you ever hear once speak out against
premeditated fraud on the fisa court
did you uh ever all he said was his quid
pro quo on tape that he's bragging about
uh and defended his son now we know a
lot more about kazakhstan
ukraine russia three and a half million
dollars oligarchs
chinese nationals private equity
i think joe biden might not be
liking his own positions coming up
fairly shortly
if this is the game he wants to play
because clearly it is or else he would
have spoken out at least once
so he never mentioned the horowitz
report so if garland comes over before
the judiciary committee
i'm going to ask him will you allow the
durham report
to be honored will you allow the
prosecutor in delaware to pre-proceed
forward against hunter biden without
interference will you take the
the durham report seriously uh i'm going
to ask garland what are you going to do
to clean up the mess created by comey
mccabe and others
and i'm dying to hear what he will say
if democrats were intellectually honest
and consistent and applied the same
standards and arguments they used on
ukraine in their impeachment hoax
and you applied it to joe you're not
getting the six
the 20 the billion dollars unless you
fire the prosecutor investigating my son
that admits he had
no experience millions if they applied
that tape and those circumstances
to joe he democrats would have to
impeach him
on day one true or false if they applied
the same standards
oh my god beyond true let's let they
accuse
the democrats uh the trump family of
doing something illegal for trying to
build a hotel in russia
if you thought that was a problem how in
the world can you give hunter biden to
pass
given everything he did taking millions
of dollars from the most corrupt company
in the ukraine
burisma going all over china to get
sweetheart
deals if you really thought the trump
family did something wrong but trying to
do business lawfully in russia
then what are you going to do about
hunter biden but i just want to end it
with this
we have a chance here to start over
president trump did the right thing
last night in the last 24 hours instead
of trying to match what president trump
has done
the radical democrats are talking about
another impeachment that will destroy
the country even further
and there's one man that can stop this
president-elect biden i hope you will
use the power you have
to stop it before it's too late i'm
going to give you some advice
unsolicited as it is senator
whatever you do don't hold your breath
you'll suffocate
uh over time because it ain't going to
happen in my opinion but thank you for
being with us
you may be right and uh god i hope it
does but if you're right god help us all
i don't think he he has it in him that's
my that's what i believe